Davis three toys brain rebound Williams
[Applause]
to get that ball Clippers only m8y stoat
'l flew williams on the fly
picked up by teeny greens like anthony
davis may have gotten a piece of that
then was centered her round defense
between both of those coaches that James
been the emphasis for the Lakers a try
by Leonard into Davis knocked away by
infinitive as he sneaks it away
through the grip of Bradley another
chance to the cast breathe the seen
finish he played great defense and Javon
struggled head of the six-point ball
game and they're presented multiple
effort stop the ball get back into the
pitches block to dump layup attempt
[Music]
[Applause]
good hands by Davis and any Flags it
down 13 turnovers from the Jazz in this
first half get Quinn cook on Donovan
Mitchell much better than the aggressive
then Avery Bradley defending look good
job that was beautiful did you wanna
know latina they go there he's stoned by
David you lion BAM not sure that Davis
the deflection caldwell-pope the steal
turnover number 21 for Utah trying to
force things to and that falls into the
hands it's another change that's he gets
back in transition
LeBron one to stop defends that played
that ad made prime example go up get
contact with the ball without getting
too much contact with the offensive
player in this game without question
he's earned his way
the rotation that's good they can be
fenced today this house with Davis
steals it once again he wants to go all
the way through the wall up but nearly
in makers have opened up a seven-point
lead up all that time and then it's out
of bounds to Charlotte what a quarter
for ad paddocks land challenges not
gonna happen
swatted away by Anthony Davis in the
next possession defensively rejects the
shot that starts too late he's going the
other way of his there put the key but
the layup just rolled off the rim Moran
likes to get to the basket and it's
backed by the Lakers good hustle by
Dwight tapped by Green can't control it
Memphis on the attack doll
nowhere to go they just spotted him up
at the rail can have a couple of subs in
a moment for the Lakers it again Avery
Bradley five assists now for James
porzingis gives it up finney-smith
underneath pliva gets denied
James and Davis both their five to shoot
you points eight assists five rebounds
not just behind the back McGee sit up
James
swings it Bradley finishes
[Applause]
[Music]
hurry Louds not sure to who to get back
to ffensive LY they finally do Aldrich
the l-train on rock by Davis Anthony's
got the rejection corner King Soopers
the basketball they cut the other way
[Music]
the shot blocker the angle should go to
the other side of the basket cut off the
angle a little bit and maybe he gets
there shut up stalking about it no rajon
rondo again that calf injury is really
lingering DeRozan blocked by AG
perfectly timed as he just swiped it
right away from Tamar bounce now the
Laveen they Chris got a trap down on the
defense nearly a steal by Caldwell club
there's a walk by Howard kcp ahead of
the pack and
with marketing give it change baby throw
it away
Levine watch Lakers at the rim not
tonight
wandering like Bucky very good play one
market in and that's what hit to JaVale
getting the uncontested dunk the Lakers
down by 13 but it's going to be under
three minutes before they get how could
you miss Anthony Davis Wendell Carter
Butler with the very first possession
Jenny had a big game the other night
especially in the first half when he
scored 30 you know where the length is
around and immediately
we'll play above the rim tonight fourth
you're looking to get at that starting
right in the passing lane reading it
beautifully is a be LeBron cross court
Avery Bradley set fire does not get
Reaper they're gonna get in you give up
a three triple-doubles enter oh good
save by the Lakers in here they cut
close pass isn't open there's that
start to talk about anthony davis the
steel he's going all the way dry [ __ ]
yes again matching it as Nancy Davis
picks off an easy interception there and
then takes it down and gets the assist
to Quinn cook 88 points 3 assists 3
rebounds so Kyle Lowry know Rondo again
tonight for the Lakers we thought we
might see him he went 5 on 5 block by ad
and again he hurt his shoulder yeah got
a 4.4 underneath Lakers got lucky on his
play
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so with six oh seven to play Lakers are
up by a point
[Applause]
Booker he's just trying to do too much
liquor side of the goichi things on the
left wing early in the game but he made
a nice read an overplay when they pass
intended for Kaminsky so he deserved the
easy deuce
Dudley out of season a time six points
in the last game against Golden State
number one in blocks in the NBA you got
another 147 accelerating and now is
trying to draw Davis in and they
actually got too much going IRA that's
where you got to pass the ball you can't
turn it over there
[Music]
Aronson has to trust itself that day and
see Fagin and they have been cheating
good and there's a leak out they get a
fast break basket Bogdanovich will take
it out get it back his back to the
basket in a dribble alive that they did
and boy he got tripped up and then ran
right into the wall Anthony shot
blocking leader Davis number one in the
NBA the verticality of dammit stumbling
Barnes boy he just suffocated him yeah
he just really look how he just he
disappears in here begins all of the
length of Anthony Davis and the Lakers
they're the ones that escape with a win
by Davis from behind oh he is a great
offensive player of it
he has shown all kind of different
skills on the defensive end
a bee was there at the end to help
preserve the 12-point lead he is sitting
on 20 points made seven buckets all
based on and that's just a great
defensive play again by ad Peter in the
NBA over 11 a game go two-man game
Gallinari boy he hits 80
there's no whistle on that play he's in
the top five in steals again this year
rolling is Adams he fumbles it away
another turnover by the Lakers here they
come Kentavious caldwell-pope Davis
momentarily that bubble was taken by the
Thunder shrewd er 3-point country is run
off there by Corning and I like this
have another turnover okay OKC on the
attack to get the first of a
home-and-home a rarity in the NBA
underneath broken up by Anthony Davis
the enchanted Tony with a monitor right
front of us
Watson basketball and football block by
Davis
a number one in the league season high
for the Thunder despite the fact they
lost to the Lakers another turnover to
cut save by Davis we're going to be off
with one two two clocks by a key
he's still number one in the NBA nicked
the rim just don't make sure you a back
screen for a law because the finally got
the alarm clock going and they've woken
up 21 block shot everything good about
that defensive possession for the Lakers
the 24 year old that's why Steve on it
yes it did I mean it was right up in the
hands but too much speed all the going
to double baby was there to place of
defense
it could buy to Barger Rosen from Topton
and USC Rosen and it's good Lake the
defense again he's gonna slash into the
basket good box-out by San Antonio
no man's land for their eighth straight
win and their fifteenth of the season
Anthony Davis gets his second block the
other end first is I got an easy one
not with Anthony Davis on the floor
nothing easy in the paint and
offensively the Blues in the fans truly
great I'm not sure it might even
motivate them a little bit more like
this one LeBron James up some light snow
Gregg Popovich just died a little bit
cuz I skipped about thanks thank you
thank you
I love the kid Williams on the drive and
Davis with the steal Lakers on the move
they've got numbers of four on scene
matter ad that gets it back at scores
how about that quick four-point play by
Caruso to tap the inbounds pass 16
seconds to go Ingram
got by Davis out of bounds what's the
[Applause]
holiday and on the ball he shaded the
top of the floor which made drew holiday
throw the ball up air time was allowed
Anthony day proud and a little bit of
disbelief she could not audibly hear the
murmurs well who is pitching the shutout
walk shot by ad Lakers of course that is
four turnovers already and we have a
break for this ball behind the back
today degree
fabrics off to their best start since
2010-11 their championship year got
chips protected by ad and it's kept in
play they stopped blitzing uh Luka and
they were having the most success they
were really quick city quick eight
points of this lead in that timeframe
[Applause]
[Music]
Rhonda way to the front court all the
way to Caruso - oh yes
Lucca goes up and the Davis is Leo Getz
asserts of South viola the game be
certainly a second
rejected by Anthony day
we shot record Elvis he was very close
to the rim
by ages
sensational plan that's a co-chair
Calvin
[Applause]
the other hand alone is kcp Rondo the
door
[Music]
volleyball he was a secondary defender
and he swats it out of bounds the Lakers
on top 550 little Pigman go with white
side good defense by Anthony Davis those
long arms getting in the way the Lakers
have numbers extra pass Guzman for nine
three is pure think Cruz was got to be a
shot maker he's been a great summer
Davis with another block and he could
pass that tonight good hustle Davis got
the deflection that Lakers depth being
tested a little bit here with Quinn cook
and they lead by 19 Whiteside block by
Anthony Davis what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content